à
[Applaudissements]
l'état du gingembre
poutine et zaz aube
monza
non berra
prénom olivier
un look de crocodile dundee qui ne doit
rien au cinéma
suis arrivé ici à
au début c'était pour faire des
inventeurs des populations de crocodiles
du madagascar exportait des peaux de
crocodile mais gendron exporter un petit
peu trop donc le commerce international
avait été suspendue et on m'a
payé pour venir compter les crocodiles
de mer gascard
et c'est vrai que tu tombe facilement
amoureux de la nature malgache
et
[Musique]
olivier est donc resté
mais aujourd'hui il est inquiet
madagascar l'île continent l'île aux
épices a perdu presque toute sa forêt
[Musique]
la fin de la saison sèche c'est la
période où les mecs qui m'ont brûlé et
là tu vois ces brumes
ça va ça va être de pire en pire on voit
il ya de la fumée là on est tellement il
est 9h30 du matin il ya des feux partout
là dans l'ouest c'est une catastrophe
n'as-tu pas tout ce pan de forêt a été
conclu
ça m'a brûlée ils vont y mettre le feu
avec ce sera un vin sec
chaque année deux cent à trois cent
mille hectares de forêt partent en fumée
[Musique]
là tu vois vraiment du brûlis les
rizières tout a été utilisé il n'y a
plus assez de surface jeudi donc
maintenant ils cherchent à cultiver
aussi sur des zones de forêts et pour ça
la technique traditionnelle c'est de
mettre le feu en fait brûler la forêt
pour la transformer en terres agricoles
mais c'est pas simple du tout dès que ça
a brûlé premier gros orage il n'y a plus
rien c'est un processus irréversible au
terme en termes écologiques cirque une
fois que la forêt elle a perdu cette
petite fille couche de sol riche en
dessous c'est de la latérite qui n'a
rien donc c'est fini pour toujours ça ne
repoussera plus naturellement après
[Musique]
les alternatives sont à l'ouest à 200km
de tananarive
sellin qu'olivier a commencé son
aventure c'est là qu'il a décidé qu'il
pourrait changer les choses
ce but le tradipraticien chef de
laboratoire maintenant
chantal vient demain
elle va arriver à 9 heures donc il
faudrait que le matin on aille un peu
dans la forêt chercher les plantes qui
des nouvelles plantes est comme ça après
quand chantal arrive vous pouvez essayer
de faire les extractions au labo ouais
[Musique]
après la route bitumée
il faut emprunter la voie ferrée
s'enfoncer dans la forêt pour enfin
découvrir l'atelier d'olive
tu as cette plante la c1 flaugnatti
forme itunes plantes à croissance assez
rapide et devront aider les feuilles on
extrait de la mort j ferrin et qui sert
à faire des crèmes solaires
et par exemple cette plante là c'est ce
qui permet de faire cette crème solaire
là et là tu as une molécule naturelle
qui en fait fait l'avenir d'agresseurs
on était passé au chimique et maintenant
on revient au naturel et pour de bonnes
raisons
des exemples comme celui ci olivier en a
des dizaines il suffit de se pencher
pour trouver l'origine d'un nouveau
médicament d'un nouveau parfum
la biodiversité mariage c'est
fantastique je dire tu regardes au bord
des chemins si tous les trois mètres à
une autre plante est intéressant tu as
un autre insecte faire un autre petit
animal dire qui est là c'est vraiment la
liberté il ya dix mille plantes
différentes ici
sur ces dix mille plants 2000 sont déjà
reconnus pour avoir des propriétés
médicinales ou aromatiques
c'est pour protéger tous là qu'olivier a
créé ici la première base de l'homme et
l'environnement son ong
la maison 20h28 monter
la réserve elle commence ici tu vois là
derrière tout est dégradé la limite
c'est la rivière
et ici donc là où on a construit la
distillerie le laboratoire jure le petit
restaurant
et là tu as la forêt qui démarre comme
en
6ieme observe la team 1 gérard woods et
jules
louis les enfants jouent au marché
ça c'est
loupé l'es17 l'aube et les insectes
d'une plante médicinale dit simon s'en
sert pour soigner le voit il entre donc
ici les enfants lieu d'avoir des jouets
en plastique il joue avec une paire avec
le pilote
parfois on trouve quand même à la
plastique regarde
[Rires]
aujourd'hui à wiman la communauté
paysanne vie grâce aux plantes
elle ne brûle plus la forêt pour planter
du manioc ou du riz
ses feuilles de gingembre papillon une
espèce sauvage qui pousse vite et par
tous constituent leurs nouvelles
ressources
il y à 88 femmes qui travaillent à la
récolte
à tour de rôle elles font peser leurs
fagots vannetais
moi je gagne 2 euros pour 100 kg
récoltés
lui de gingembre papillon est précieuse
pour ses vertus calmantes et antistress
elle est vendue à des sociétés
d'aromathérapie d'
le principe d'extraction et est super
simple en fait c'est le cd principe
quand on était mieux emplois du temps
des égyptiens tu as des molécules
aromatiques dans les feuilles donc tu as
des comme s'il ya des micros poche qui
sont à l'intérieur de ça en fait on a
fait rentrer de la vapeur au fond de
l'alambic la vapeur va traverser les
feuilles remontée
est donc là la vapeur va se transformer
en eau dans laquelle il y aura un
mélange d'huiles essentielles
des communes est essentielle et plus
légère que l'eau
là ça va séparer
et nous on va récupérer la partie
supérieure de ce liquide qui va être lui
l'essentiel
un petit trésor vendu 400 euros le litre
mais qui se mérite
voici la production d'une cuve entière
un fonds de bouteilles à peine qu'un
centilitres
une vallée plus loin
cet autre distillerie fourni l'une des
plus grandes marques de parfumerie au
monde
son atout le gingembre blur
c'est une variété de gingembre mais qui
est tout petit et qui est super
concentré en principe actif et au début
le premier usage qu'on en a fait c'était
donc en cosmétique pour faire des supers
crème super chic que super luxe et après
on s'est rendu compte aussi que quand
ils distillent tu peux avoir une huile
essentielle qui a aussi un parfum
extraordinaire
l'autre intérêt de cette variété de
gingembre et qu'elle se cultive très
facilement là un bas mais c'est une
plantation d un des membres
chaque année les rhizomes sont replantés
ils se multiplient ensuite par cinq ou
six de quoi alimenter régulièrement la
distillerie
mêlée claude entre
6000 à catalent kg
les paysans ont donc de revenus l'un
pour leurs récoltes et l'autre pour leur
travail à la distillerie
à la place de sortir bêtement 3 tonnes
tu vois de gingembre pour aller vers un
alambic tous les jours bah tu vas sortir
1 kg d'huile et c'est ça un peu
l'innovation qu'on a fait ici c'était de
se dire se donner le challenge de former
les gens ici pour qu'ils fassent
l'extraction sur place
la forêt malgache est donc une
gigantesque pharmacie où chaque arbre
chaque planche grâce à ces molécules est
susceptible de guérir une maladie
ça c'est drôle sert à madagascar et à
nice c'est une petite plante carnivore
qui pousse sur des zones très très
pauvres là tu vois les sur de sol sur la
tourbe c'est pour ça qu'elle a
développée en fait c'est attrape mouches
qui lui permet de se nourrir à partir de
mouches et cette petite plante là est
déjà exporté et quand tu vois ça doit
bien qui a un air madagascar exporte 5
tonnes par heure de ce petit truc
riquiqui la hesse qui sert à faire des
sirops antitussifs en europe
mais les surprises ne s'arrêtent pas au
monde végétal
c'est une et fils
le fils de cette araignée
servait du temps des rois et des petits
c'est dire qu'avec ça il faisait des
étoiles et c'est assez extraordinaire ce
fil est tellement solide il sert
maintenant en chirurgie aux états unis
il est utilisé parce que en fait il est
hypoallergénique
comme c'est un matériau totalement
naturel si tu veux pour la chirurgie
réparatrice
il n'était pas du tout d'allergie
l'armée américaine travaille dessus pour
faire des gilets pare balles donc en
fait à placer un gros truc lourds qui te
retrouves à capter gillet pire tous faim
est tout mignon et hyper solide parce
que ce fil est hyper hyper solide
seules les femelles peuvent tisser une
toile pour récupérer leurs précieux
filaments elles sont capturés et placés
dans ces curieuses installation en moins
de 25 minutes elles peuvent produire
plus de 30 mètres de fil
un peu plus loin dans la forêt
[Musique]
un son insolite
traverse la vallée
le clip des intérêts et des
communications
[Musique]
les lits iddri sont les plus grands des
lémuriens
on a beaucoup dansé pas un oui beaucoup
ils ont ce cri qui leur permet de se
retrouver au coeur de la forêt de savoir
qui ou quoi et ça c'est un cri qui porte
à des kilomètres dans les collines et
qui permet quand il ya une famille qui
s'éclate famille et là c'est
schématiquement à l'eau et tout va bien
tout le monde est bien là et tout va
bien
pour les voir il suffit donc de savoir
se connecter au réseau
jean paul connaît le hendry dans ses
moindres détails
les indh ribéry c'est habité de trois
écrits red alert cri d'amour
quid appelle la crise d'appel à
4,6 et ça c'est que les dames au comme
le blues ou 6 et les papes l'élégance il
faut prendre les cuit les papas donc
bien bien bien bien bien ils sont là bas
ça se vend bien regarde sont là bas
les indh riz vivent et dorment dans les
arbres
[Musique]
leur détente est sidérante
leur main aux longs doigts sont très
proches de celles des hommes
[Musique]
les lémuriens sont très en danger tu
veux suivant les espèces plus que
d'autres mais il a grande détresse pour
les murs et c'est la perte d'habitat car
quand il ya plus de forêts les indh riz
ils ne vivent que dans la forêt
impossible de les tenir en captivité ils
mangent plusieurs dizaines d'espèces
tous les jours donc s'il ya plus fort il
ya plus de lémuriens
la forêt de wheelman couvre environ 2000
hectares
c'est la seule surface boisée de
madagascar qui ne régressent pas
mais on arrive à la pépinière
parce qu'en fait là tu vois les la forêt
qui reste comme on a réussi à enrayer
maintenant la déforestation on peut se
permettre de démarrer des programmes de
reboisement est ici sur vous iman ya
déjà eu plus de 450 mille arbres qui ont
été plantés
et y poursuivre maintenant le travail et
même à restaurer des parcelles dire
qu'ils ont été dégradés ces pépinières
sont financées par les entreprises qui
achètent les huiles essentielles leurs
investissements à long terme garantisse
la pérennité des matières premières
j'appelle donne des boulots pour les
alentours paquet là ils sont des hommes
qui vivent aux alentours des maisons des
bouleaux avec ça mais jamais fait
plaisir on s'aime beaucoup les dépôts
tenait
à chaque sortie en forêt olivier emporte
sa bible un inventaire de poche des
espèces médicinales de la région
spécialement édité par l'omg la cds et
les crises
clandestine a donc tu vois là on
retrouve dans la nature la plante qu'on
a identifié sur le livre
bleu n'y a rien en médecine
international industriel qu'est ce qui
lie 6,6 contre la fièvre jaune
et la fatigue haussier et la fatigue
de retour au labo
monsieur le samedi le médecin
traditionnel local se met au travail
j'ai dû apprendre la télé m'a mis les
genres les classifications scène après
dix ans
tu vois ce que disait le sahb août il
disait tout à l'heure il n'a 130 plants
qui l'a identifié y pense qu'il arrivera
à 160 à la fin de son travail l'année
prochaine donc tu as des plantes
médicinales on peut vraiment trouver des
miracles wef et ce n'est pas une parole
en l'air ici sont et des stars de
l'industrie cosmétique
quand il ya cinq ans on s'est dit on va
construire ce petit labo je dirais puis
on va essayer d'arriver à faire quelque
chose et maintenant tu as le marron gris
qui a été mise au point entre ici et les
laboratoires là bas mais comme la base d
extraction c'est chantal qui les fait
avec lesabotsy si tu as pour le faire et
ce produit va sortir ça va être le
prochain produit phare de chez chanel
donc c'est dire qu'on est capable ici de
trouver le top du top parce que c'est
les plantes le top tu vas c'est pas
c'est pas nous qui sommes le meilleur
technicien du mans c'est la nature qui
t'offre tout ça
[Musique]
banias s'est vite
quand je suis arrivé ici c'était une
catastrophe tu vois je n'avais pas accès
à la santé il fallait marcher 12 km un
pied je veux dire pour trouver le
premier infirmiers il ya donc là tu peux
pas tu peux pas faire du développement
si tu as pas des corps saints comme on
dit tu vois j'ai donc là c'était pas
possible j'ai rien vu tessa
nocives et voir en bas vagnas compte
aujourd'hui 1500 habitants dont 800
enfants ils font aujourd'hui leur
rentrée des classes
est hulot un crayon de papier une règle
un cahier qui assure que j'ai bien ses
devoirs séverine qui sont en option
parce que investir situé dans un pays
comme ça je dirais plus d'avoir des
enfants qui vont à l'école pts à
plaindre qu'à des études qu'ils font
plein de gens veulent construire des
écoles ce qui est difficile c'est de
faire que j'ai démarré sa ya dix ans les
écoles sont sur la nature des gens qui
les encadrent tu vois et puis c'est ça
qui progresse et c'est un vrai coup de
pouce que tu peux donner et non pas tant
occupé en permanence et ça la grosse
différence ici et ça ça me fait vraiment
plaisir
après les cours
direction le potager pour les travaux
pratiques
c'est un jardin d'apprentissage
l'objectif c'est à la fois donc de
pouvoir communiquer quelques notions en
termes de culture maraîchère et
d'agriculture en termes de nutrition
également et quelques notions
élémentaires de sciences naturelles et
de connaissances usuelles
l'autre victoire de l'omg
l'autre victoire de la forêt c'est ce
centre de soins
mais là on est dans le centre de santé
mais sur lequel a été adjoint salle
d'accouchement enfin ce qu'elle veut il
ya une petite fille qui vient de naître
cette nuit donc on va aller voir pour
accueillir alice le nouveau né toute la
famille a fait le déplacement
comme ils sont loin isolé tu peux pas
juste avoir un lit sinon la famille il
peut pas être là comme ils viennent de
très très loin pied ces trucs auxquels
tu penses pas au début c'est pas des
logiques occident c'est ça qu'il faut
écouter les gens le centre compte
actuellement deux salariés une sage
femme et une infirmière
quand je passais elle me voyait passer
tout le temps elle habite dans un autre
village le premier village puis un coup
et nous voir quand elle a vu ça tu vas
les débuts du web mais là moi je suis
infirmier
[Rires]
de bloc et se faire dorer produire tu
vas pas la laisser partir de pas si elle
peut travailler dans ce sens dans son
village
il y à 50 ans
toutes ces collines été couverte
d'arbres
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la forêt ne représente plus
que 7% de la surface de l'île
c'est sur la côte est à huit heures de
route et de piste
sur les bords de l'océan indien que
subsistent l'un des derniers massive
là on est arrivé à malange bat on va
traverser le lac et on va remonter le
canal pendant une heure et demie pour
arriver jusqu'à la forêt de louis bull
qui est ce dernier reliquat de forêt
primaire de la forêt littorale vous dire
qu'on a quand même on a ici il ya quatre
espèces d'arbres qui sont menacés
d'extinction immédiate
[Musique]
à la barre les
malades
[Musique]
c'est sur les bords du canal des
pangalanes
qu'olivier a une nouvelle fois trouvé la
solution
grâce à ces arbres qui poussent les
pieds dans l'eau
tout ça c'est du niaouli donc on note
dont on extrait une huile essentielle
lorsqu'on a fait c'est qu'on a ramené
ici aussi par le canal des alambics au
village qu'on va voir et maintenant ils
distillent ils produisent du niari
plusieurs centaines de kilos par an
d'huiles essentielles qui est très anti
bactérienne qui utilisés en pharmacie en
parfumerie ça marcherait pas parce que
l'odeur est pas terrible terrible mais
qui a des forts pouvoirs antimicrobiens
et qui est utilisé aussi bien ou
parapharmacies quand l'aromathérapie
ponton
olivier connaissez villageois depuis 15
ans
jean-paul bonjour comment ça va ça va
bien très bien moins sûr alors comment
ça va
andrade à coup tu étais un village en
grande difficulté
il subsistait grâce à la pêche mais
surtout en abattant des arbres pour en
faire du charbon de bois
aujourd'hui grâce aux feuilles de
niaouli
ils peuvent compter sur un revenu
régulier sans détruire la forêt
et depuis peu à la distillerie un
nouveau pas a été franchi
là tu vois il fait sécher les feuilles
pour faire fonctionner la les chaudières
est donc là maintenant y situe à 0
consommation de bois c'est que les frais
qui mange ça marche pas dans la
chaudière améliorée
c'est génial parce qu'avant ici pour
faire une cuisson donc pour avoir 2
litres et demi l'huile il fallait une
stères de bois il a suffi qu'on fasse
venir deux jeunes ingénieurs français
ont leur âme et un petit challenge j'ai
trouvé nous une solution technique est
là maintenant il utilise moins de
feuilles pour faire chauffer une cuve
qu'il n'en distille donc volontiers
totalement autonome en bois ya plus de
toute utilisation bois pour distiller
la vie ça s'appelle comment
le fils itium c'est une plante
médicinale pour contre la fatigue qu'on
peut prendre un petit elle sera plus
grande
et la pêche
dans la pépinière de huy bull chaque
visiteur à une mission il doit planter
son arbre on va aller
eh ben ça canal quand ciom plus de 10
variétés d'arbres sont disponibles à vis
bull le programme de reboisement et
personnaliser
chaque parent peut même suivre la
croissance de son arbre sur internet
donc je viens de planter mon arbre et
puis chez le point gps pour le retrouver
par satellite une fois qu'il aura grandi
un peu je serai peut-être très bien à ce
moment là
une approche ludique et efficace dans
toutes les zones reboisées la faune
malgache s'est immédiatement
réapproprier les lieux ici c'est très
simple tous mettent à des petits
ruisseaux des fois tu avais des bébés
crocodiles et l'accès impossible de les
voir deux jours mais des fois dans l'est
dans les petits ruisseaux ou ailleurs je
sais qu'il ya un petit ruisseau l'oeuf
olivier retrouve très vite ses réflexes
de chasseurs de croco d'unir
une espèce
du mozambique
pour nicher dans les lacs de madagascar
ils ont dû traverser un bras de mer de
plus de 400 km
il était aux aguets les tout petits les
de l'année il pourrait atteindre 5 m 56
m s'il était très vieux
[Applaudissements]
accueil extrêmement puissante c'est
vraiment des animaux
tu as accepté tout un muscle en longueur
donc c'est ce qui leur donne leur
capacité de nager dans l'eau mais aussi
de surtout de bondir au bord de l'eau
alors il a trois paupières déjà tu
regardes au niveau de l'eau quand il met
sa tête dans l'eau tu as juste les
narines qui sortait les yeux qui sera
même une paupière tu as une troisième
paupières qui est une paupière
transparente tu vois quand il ferme le
tac toe ses paupières là qui est
transparent face à ça veut dire que en
fait quand il est sous l'eau il peut
garder ses yeux ouverts ils essaient
comédie mettait son masque voix et
autres vous à l'intérieur de la bouche
aussi
il a un clapet qui lui permettent
d'ouvrir sa gueule sous l'eau sans se
voyait quoi
[Musique]
bonjour au maire
d'agde et baladeur au oui non mais enfin
qu'est ce que tu veux mon nom je suis je
fais des phlébites pas lui bien sûr et
j'ai attrapé mère métisse fiche
et pourtant le vaccin n'est toi mais ça
mange pas tous les cours mais c'est pas
une maladie désagréable en ce sens que
c'est complètement inconscient dana
vasculaire complètement et a rien qui se
passe dans la tête tu aux
éducateurs à la retraite robert a
construit une demi-douzaine de bâtiments
pour les ong
actuellement il est sur un projet
insolite qui mobilise toutes les forces
vives du village
ça ce sont les joueurs de foot de
l'équipe de tom binn qui sont en train
de creuser le canal pour sortir le
bateau solaire
[Applaudissements]
l' enthousiasme des footballeurs
terrassiers de telles que dans deux
semaines la communauté disposera d'un
nouveau bateau municipal à énergie
solaire
[Musique]
a déjà débarqué sur
l'île de nocibé
au nord de madagascar
il y a urgence
ces lacs de cratère peut-être plus tard
et une minute ces tempêtes
il ya des poissons endémique parfois de
chaque l'acquis sister des poissons que
tu trouve nulle part au monde qui s'y
est parce que les paysans ils ont rien
d'autre que de la culture sur brûlis ils
ont brûlé ici le chant pour planter des
trucs qui vont rapporter rien du tout et
là tu arrives à un phénomène d'érosion
qui va nous ramener de la terre dans le
lac et les poissons ils sont habitués à
une qualité de l'eau et parce qu'ils
n'auront plus cette qualité de l'eau et
ben ils vont étouffer ils vont en mourir
et tu as le même processus au niveau des
récifs coralliens c'est là que la
production de 70 % de 2 des réserves
marines des poissons dans l'ensemble des
océans se fait dans les récifs
coralliens donc là on est en train de
détruire parce qu'on n'est pas capable
de filer un coup de pouce aux paysans
pour qu'il fasse autre chose que de la
culture sur brûlis
les lacs de cratère constitue également
la seule ressource d'eau potable de
lille
il a donc fallu trouver un moyen pour
changer les habitudes
et fixer le sol des berges là c'est en
fait c'est du vétiver qui est fait pour
montrer comment fixe le sol comment on
arrête l'érosion avec ses bandes d'herbe
qui vont pousser et qui ont un système
racinaire très très fort et bah quand
ils vont être toujours un tiff une fois
qu'ils auront un peu grandi quand le sol
il se retrouve arrêté par c'est parce
vétiver qu'est plantaire et le but c'est
d'arriver à protéger la qualité des eaux
du des lacs grâce en mettant du vétiver
tout le long et après ils ont planté au
milieu du lit dans ghislain
l'ylang ylang
ses fleurs sont l'or jaune de madagascar
importés d'asie du sud est il est
productif quatre ans après avoir été
plantés
ylang ylang est un parfum très très
puissant très fort très fleurie qui est
utilisé dans beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de parfums mais tient aussi des
propriétés antioxydantes dire qu'ils
sont attisées maintenant en cosmétique
pour la qualité des cheveux c'est
vraiment un chouette produit
le marché de l'ylang ylang est
international avec le tourisme il fait
quasiment vivre tous les habitants de
l'île
lorsqu'il y en a beaucoup lors de la
saison et un que deux otages est à
revoir environ 30 kg ils sont payés par
mois ça dépend des quantités qu'elle
obtenus durant un mois
deschamps 59 mg
250 euros c'est deux fois plus que le
salaire minimum de madagascar
l'ylang ylang doit absolument se
cueillir à l'eau
car de sa fraîcheur dépend la qualité de
son huile essentielle
ça c'est l'échantillon donc de la
qualité supérieure qu'on va ramener en
france pour le faire analyser et c'est
là où on va essayer de filer un coup de
main à dana pour que lui-même puisque
filer un coup de main aux communautés
ici et qui trouvent des marchés plus
direct
plus l'huile et de qualité et plus elle
se vend cher
à une petite porte
pour eux surtout je veux dire c'est eux
qui vont qu'ils vont faire tous les
soirs avec ça mais effectivement tu vois
il ya plus de 1000 euros et quand tu
penses que le salaire minimum il est à
100 euros par mois donc ça veut dire que
là tu fais vivre à une dizaine de
personnes chaque fois ci tous les mois
ils exportent ça
depuis 50 lots ngc doté d'une vraie
structure professionnelle pour assurer
le contrôle qualité des productions
elle fonctionne comme une entreprise
privée
là on arrive chez à dallas donc là on va
aller voir ce qu'il fait c'est lui
maintenant qui gère totalement
totalement à romain forest et qui fait
les exportations et contrôle qualité qui
fait le commercial c'est le mais le
maillon manquant que ne peuvent pas
faire les communautés locales
dans le match et loire
toutes les huiles essentielles produite
par l' ong transit donc ici pour être
filtrés analyser et enfin certifié avant
l'exportation vous avez combien une
dizaine d'huiles essentielles maintenant
quinze villes qui vont donc d ylang
ylang qu'on a vu jusqu'au sarocchi aussi
utilisé en cosmétique qui part chez yves
rossy aussi il ya des
des géraniums un petit peu qu'ils
partent aussi chez des clients de
parfumerie et gingembre c'est qu'il va
partir pour chanel va aussi passer par
ce par cette place-là
plusieurs échantillons sont préparés
donc tu me donnes ça tue mes tickets de
ça pour man et puis si tu veux des toi
tu m'en donnes trois autres que je
préfère
c'est bon
moi je récupère
olivier part demain pour la france
[Musique]
il doit rencontrer des parfumeurs mais
aussi les grandes marques de la
cosmétique
paris est à 9000 kilomètres plus de dix
heures d'avion
[Musique]
un aéroport charles de gaulle
olivier n'est pas venu les mains vides
[Musique]
tous ces rendez-vous sont dans les beaux
quartiers
attention les champs elysées un pareil
c'est un peu boisée je ne sais pas c'est
pas les mêmes faudrait quand même et là
on va aller chercher de son jardin des
partenaires con
on a réussi à impliquer dans le système
et qui cherchent à s'approvisionner
maintenant de façon bien déterminée
savoir d'où viennent les produits donc
je leur amène des nouveaux produits et
on essaie de les impliquer avec des
actions de terrain aussi ce qui
maintient le
groupe collabore depuis trois ans avec
l'homme et l'environnement
bonjour mesdames
avec son chapeau et le 10 mai 10 mais il
a toujours dit la thalasso c'est
tout le monde n'a pas la chance d'aller
dans les sessions de chant
[Rires]
avec kg dit la responsable des produits
olivier présente l'ylang ylang de nocibé
va très bien
je terminais un petit échantillon des
productions qui sont sur site maintenant
tu peux envoyer cinq usines oui ils vont
voir si si ça colle au niveau de la
qualité ce qui a été fait
c'est formidable mais lorsqu elle
s'adonne d'un
shampooing
donc nous on utilise l'huile essentielle
qu'on incorpore un autre formule de
shampoing les notes shampoing pour
cheveux secs et fragilisé voilà si tu
veux lorsqu'il sort un aperçu ce que ça
donne
donc retour comme un
secret bien rester un bon mélange assez
bien c'est rare des shampoings les plus
plébiscités nos gars comme c'est là
notre coeur de cible en terme de
clientèle il marche très il fonctionne
benjamin dessange le patron entraîne aux
oliviers dans le salon prestige de la
marque
il souhaite qu'ils rencontrent les
clientes
comment vous vous sentez
c'est tout à fait génial parce que
l'effectif bonjour ça fait quand même un
contraste tu vois entre les zones de
production
c'est pas le même milieu
mais c'est bien de voir à quoi ça sert
c'est vachement génial de faire le lien
la prochaine fois vous viendrez là-bas
dans la forêt
je pense que c'est un vrai sujet je
pense que c'est très intéressant et
important de connaître la provenance en
effet
le succès commercial des produits
naturels est en plein expansion
olivier veille à ce qu'il ne se limite
pas à une simple opération de marketing
il faut pas se raconter des histoires
général les gens qui sont là ils vivent
dans le luxe ils sont à 100 milieu si tu
veux de de gens impliqués dans des zones
qui il faut être réaliste la règle c'est
de dire moi je vais pas venir faire le
clown je veux dire discuter avec les
gens parler des choses si c'est juste
pour avoir des produits équitables non
si vous voulez jouer le jeu on va jouer
le jeu jusqu'au bout sire que benjamin
deux ans que vous allez vous impliquez
vous allez financer des actions de
terrain c'est pas juste acheter des
produits équitables il faut qu'il ait
une vraie implication des gens du nord
maintenant pour préserver cette forêt
qui est mais le capital qui est ce qui
est la réserve des produits naturels qui
sont les actifs donc les gens ils ne
voient pas obligatoirement chacun est
dans son monde et il faut des gens qui
fassent le lien et que les entreprises
s'engagent il faut qu'elles s'engagent
pour de vrais
ambassadeurs et négociateur de talent
olivier obtenu gain de cause chez
plusieurs grandes marques de cosmétiques
elle finance tout aujourd'hui des
programmes de développement durable
dans un 100 m prenez la deuxième sortie
vers antonis
près de grasse chez man la sixième
entreprise mondiale de création d'arômes
et de parfums
olivier veut passer à la vitesse
supérieure un pari qui est loin d'être
gagné
là on va essayer de trouver des gens qui
sont capables d'acheter des volumes
importants de développer des nouveaux
produits en parfumerie mais surtout
d'acheter des volumes beaucoup plus
important que des petits développeurs ou
que de l'industrie cosmétique
dans son sac olivier esper avoir apporté
de quoi séduire est ce que je peux vous
faire sentir un truc que moi j'ai
clairement fait qu'ils ont été faits à
madagascar mais qui
quitte pas du tout des odeurs classique
qu'on a c'est très peu de rendement mais
ça j'aimerais bien voir votre avis
ligny de l'entreprise passe l'odeur au
crible
étrange étrange l'herbe des rois jeunes
ont déjà n'est ce pas
mais bon c'est pas assez c'est pas
péjoratif
au niveau industriel les places sont
chères
quand on revit en fait j'aurais toujours
la rationalité et puis bon jour les
échanges qu'on a
sur les contraintes industrielles mais
avant avant tout aussi c'est d'éviter
géré par contre je restais de donner de
faux espoirs pour les nouvelles essences
seul un projet sur dix abouti
deuxième problème du naturel toujours
c'est avec les réglementations qu'il ya
ou où on a
on a des fois des soucis d'utilisation
parce qu'il faut pas nés les rejette sur
les produits finis donc malheureusement
la thur n ya toujours
un petit peu court des ppn quand c'est
pas des pourcentages cdp pme des
produits qui sont de constitution qui
sont classés allergènes donc d'entendre
des difficultés à l'utiliser
ppm abréviation qui signifie parties par
million en clair cela veut dire que même
en quantité infinie mans petit un
composant d'une nouvelle huile
essentielle peut provoquer des allergies
l'avenir industriel de l'huile est alors
compromis
il faut plus de cinq ans pour qu'une
nouvelle huile passe tous les tests une
fois certifiée elle est utilisée en
fonction son prix
on a des matières premières jouent et
qui vont représenter gérer quelques
dizaines d'euros due au kilo et d'autre
en fait je qui vont représenter j'aurais
plusieurs milliers d'euros au kilo donc
tous largeur est d'arriver en fait à
jongler et associés justement ces
matières premières en respectant aussi
les contraintes financières j'aurais
d'un brief puisque lorsque l'on
travaille un prono clients nous en fait
on travaille au niveau de prix demandé
par notre client
juste pour l'hexagone le marché des
huiles essentielles représente plus d'un
milliard d'euros
le plus gros des volumes de production
est utilisée pour les savons les gels de
douche mais aussi pour masquer les
odeurs désagréables des détergents dans
les produits de nettoyage
les plus chères sont réservés à la
parfumerie fine
l'amérique comme acheter gérer plusieurs
grosses voitures en
cette pâte est fait à partir de ryzom
d'iris elle coûte plus deux cent mille
euros le kilo
l'avenir de la forêt serait-il par
l'argent moi je me suis retrouvé des cas
les vire ya 20 ans il ya 15 ans quand
j'ai commencé à lire il faut inclure de
l'économie dans l'environnement mais
qu'est ce que fait olivier il fait du
business ou alors il fait de
l'environnement donc là maintenant et je
me dis tiens il faut peut-être penser
autrement donc là je deviens un peu un
alien je deviens un précurseur donc ça
ça devient génial maintenant maintenant
il faut qu'on arrive à accélérer les
choses puisque maintenant les gens ont
faim ils sont prêts à accepter ces
nouveaux modèles se dire on va inclure
de l'économie dans l'environnement et on
va pas le faire l'un opposé à l'autre
mais non on arrive dans quelque chose
qui ça fait du sens pour les gens au
salon du bio à paris
olivier a rendez vous avec un ancien
stagiaire qui s'est lancé dans
l'aromathérapie s'est un peu perdu
ce stand est quelque part au milieu des
500 exposants est ce que vous savez pour
aller au numéro au au
hockey merci beaucoup
ici il y a de tous
et tout se veut bio
karité sauvage et tout karité du monde
et sauvage donc là tu vois aussi un peu
on est à la limite entre les gens super
engagé qui sont géniaux et quand même un
peu de marketing des fois qui va un peu
loin
salut ça va bien
et gagne des sous bonjour
mais là on est chez simon c'est simon
qui a monté sa petite société as terral
simon qui est un pur et dur un vrai tu
veux un qui a été formé chez moi il ya
quelques années et qui a monté sa petite
sa petite entreprise qui vend des huiles
on peut parler la cannelle par exemple
au niveau immunitaire ça c'est une
plante qui est formidable en huiles
essentielles assez délicate et utilisé
parce que très agressive là vous avez un
produit qui est d'un usage beaucoup plus
familiale plus grand public donc on va
par exemple appliquer mettre directement
en bouche
plusieurs poubelles ce prêt
donc je peux prendre salivaire pour se
protéger c'est très bien
l'engouement des français pour les
plantes médicinales est phénoménal ils
sont aujourd'hui les deuxièmes
consommateurs européens juste après les
allemands
grâce à cette demande chaque année de
nouvelles plantes de nouveaux produits
sont découverts et mis sur le marché
le sarrau c'est moi qui l'ait mis au
point qui a inventé le nom sarraut tu
vois il ya dix ans il n'y a pas plus que
ça maintenant qu'il a vu des gens qui te
disent moi ça m'a changé la vie ça m'a
soigné sam a souligné l'esprit ça va
soigner le corps c'était antibactérien
quand j'ai mis une star au point je
l'aimé parce que les malgaches dans
l'ouest malgache il utilisait une plante
qui s'appelle en malgache le monde
ravassard ou pas faire de marketing avec
ça mais le nom même de la plante c'est à
dire qui tient le mât l'éloigner ensuite
j'ai plus est non gelée distiller peu et
simon étaient à l'époque stagiaire chez
moi tu vois j'ai fait et quand après je
suis passé en laboratoire de chimie tu
regardes tu la teste sur différentes
bactéries et la papa papa tu te rends
compte que la plante ils sont et où j'ai
même retourné les champions au labo
parce que ça soigne et tellement touchés
ils ont dû se tromper les mecs qui me
revoilà deuxième analyse tu sais des
staphylocoques dorés des machins comme
ça qu'on n'arrive pas à soigner dans les
hôpitaux par clsa rôle était efficace
pour tous ces trucs là c'est donc
logiquement que de plus en plus de
plantes s'affiche aujourd'hui dans les
pharmacies peau
là on est vraiment dans des produits
pharmaceutiques avec des vertus
thérapeutiques et tu vas par exemple ici
avoir de l'ailé crise de madagascar
qu'est ce que c'est écrit c'est une
petite plante qu'on va trouver avoue
émane donc dans la forêt ou en été et
qui va être utilisée ici pour tous les
problèmes respiratoires pour les grippes
les angines c'est parfait c'est
antibactérienne et antivirale
donc ça va traiter beaucoup mieux une
angine c'est viral virtu la soigne pas
je dire avec des antibiotiques
et là tu vas avoir un traitement qui va
être pas refaire une des zi crise mais
les médicaments ont commencé à partir
des plantes la première plante il ya eu
le quinquina l'acide salicylique
l'aspirine qui a été extraite du sol
enfin ya énormément depuis 20 ans 50%
des médicaments anticancéreux qui ont
été mis au point en 8es à partir de
logique de plantes de molécules
identifiés dans des plantes et tu as des
médicaments jure donc là madagascar
exporte des des containers entiers de
pervenche de madagascar qui sert à créer
un médicament contre la leucémie
infantile 80% des enfants qui sont
atteints de leucémies infantiles
maintenant sont traitées grâce à cette
petite pervenche de madagascar
l'hémisphère nord
soigné par l'hémisphère sud
réalité ou utopie
[Musique]
c'est à tananarive qu'olivier apporte sa
réponse
dans cette maison
une équipe de jeunes ingénieurs malgache
forts de leur expérience acquise avec
l'homme et l'environnement conseil
depuis un an d'autres ong un peu partout
dans le monde
et là tu es un bon exemple au népal il
avait déjà de la production de certaines
villes mais qui était juste vendu en
inde à bas prix et donc le boulot de
chantal c'est de regarder les analyses
et devoirs je dirais pour que les huiles
qui produisent là bas savoir comment on
va les normaliser pour qu'elles trouvent
des marchés qui soit plus intéressant
auprès d'industriels plutôt qu'avec des
intermédiaires vendues pas cher
simplement parce qu'il ya un tout petit
manque de technique
le succès de la structure est
impressionnant
on a un an et demi on a développé dix
projets donc on a des projets au népal
qu'on est à dire au cambodge madagascar
bien sûr celle historique au cameroun
burkina faso bénin au sénégal on vient
de démarrer le pérou l'équateur le
nicaragua la colombie donc hélas c'était
la première phase en un an et demi on a
pu faire ça donc nous on est sûr que
dire que si on continue à voir cette
équipe qui nous permet de coordonner on
est efficace on est à bas prix et on
arrivera en fait à développer 50 cent
projets
loin des programmes institutionnels d
inertie administrative
la petite équipe d'olivier a ouvert la
voie
aujourd'hui grâce à des programmes
simples et efficaces en replaçant les
populations locales au centre des
programmes de protection de leur
environnement
chacun y trouve son compte
[Musique]